Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件目前正在发生的激动人心的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“Race to Recurring Revenue”挑战。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会直接赢取Lisa提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南。欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客，我是Marianne Trent博士。
I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. This is episode 51 of the podcast series. We have not long celebrated the 11-month which was on christmas eve in 2021 so we're fast approaching a whole year of this and it's been lovely being part of your world having you be part of my world and hearing all the lovely things you've said about the podcast i hope you find today useful and as ever if you do like the series please do leave me a review and leave me a rating on apple podcast it's so appreciated i know from looking at the stats recently that over 48 percent of you listen via spotify and that 38 percent of you listen via apple podcast which means 38 percent
我是Marianne Trent博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。这是本播客系列的第51集。我们不久前刚庆祝了2021年平安夜的11个月纪念日，所以我们很快就要迎来这一周年了。能成为你们世界的一部分，让你们成为我世界的一部分，并听到你们对播客的所有美好评价，真是太棒了。我希望今天的节目对你有用，一如既往，如果你喜欢这个系列，请务必在Apple Podcast上给我留下评论和评分，我非常感激。我最近查看数据发现，你们中有超过48%的人通过Spotify收听，38%的人通过Apple Podcast收听，这意味着38%
of you could whilst you're listening to this show right now, head on to the app, click on show, and then very easily leave me a rating and just leave me a quick review whilst you're doing it as well. And you can do it whilst you're listening. There is no need to, you know, even break stride from whatever you're doing. Stay safe. Don't do it when you're driving. That is my firm advice, obviously. If you are watching on YouTube, it won't have missed your attention that I have suddenly got no headphones on. My headphones suddenly decided to stop working and I couldn't hear myself. But I've checked and the microphone is still working. So yeah, fingers crossed, this is all fine. So today's podcast episode was dreamed up
的人可以在收听本节目时，直接打开应用程序，点击节目，然后非常轻松地给我留下评分，顺便写个简短的评论。你可以在收听的同时完成这些操作。不需要停下你正在做的事情。注意安全。显然，我坚决建议不要在开车时操作。如果你正在YouTube上观看，你一定注意到了我突然没戴耳机了。我的耳机突然停止工作，我听不到自己的声音。但我检查过了，麦克风还在工作。所以，祈祷一切顺利。今天的播客节目是我在
about 10 minutes ago by me because I was going to be doing a guest episode and it's been cancelled. And so I needed to come up with a plan for what to talk to you about. So I thought I would talk to you about some of the bits and pieces that I've been talking to people about on socials today, specifically LinkedIn, because you guys know I'm a big LinkedIn geek. If you're not already connected with me on there, do come over and find me. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent. So today I was stopped in my tracks by a lovely status, a lovely post that Zahra Bilal had shared and she was talking about an Islamic principle that is the practice of Tawakkal. I'm sorry if I've said that wrong and it's a concept of emotional detachment from an outcome. Specifically Wikipedia tells us that it's in the Arabic language and it's the word for the Islamic concept of the reliance on God, of trusting in God's plans. It's seen as a perfect trust in God and
大约10分钟前想到的，因为我原本要录制一期嘉宾访谈，但被取消了。所以我需要制定一个谈话计划。于是我想，不如和大家聊聊我今天在社交媒体上，特别是LinkedIn上与人讨论的一些零碎话题，因为你们知道我是个LinkedIn极客。如果你还没在上面关注我，一定要来找我。我是Marianne Trent博士。今天，我被Zahra Bilal分享的一条可爱的状态所吸引，她谈到了一个伊斯兰原则，即“Tawakkal”的修行。如果我读错了，我很抱歉。这是一种对结果进行情感抽离的概念。维基百科告诉我们，这是阿拉伯语，是伊斯兰教中关于依赖真主、信任真主计划的概念。它被视为对真主的完美信任，以及
reliance on him alone and it can also be referred to as God consciousness. So I kind of like this idea regardless of whether you have faith in any God or any religion at all, I kind of like this idea, regardless of whether you have faith in any God or any religion at all. I kind of like this idea because it resonated with me for kind of thinking about our journey in psychology. And then there was also a comment on there that there was also a similar Hindu practice as well and it was Anirudh Zala who'd said that in Hinduism and probably every other religion as well he said there's a concept called Nishkama Karma and so I had a little google about that let me tell you about Nishkama Karma and it's the selfless or desireless action so when an action is performed without any expectation of fruits or results and of course this is particularly useful for us when we're thinking about the process of applying for jobs and applying for training places
完全依赖于他，也可以被称为“真主意识”。无论你是否信仰任何神或宗教，我都挺喜欢这个想法，因为它引起了我的共鸣，让我思考我们在心理学领域的旅程。评论区里还有人提到，印度教中也有类似的修行，Anirudh Zala说在印度教以及可能所有其他宗教中，都有一个概念叫“Nishkama Karma”。我查了一下，Nishkama Karma指的是无私或无欲的行动，即在没有任何对成果或回报的期待下执行行动。当然，当我们考虑申请工作和培训名额时，这特别有用，
this can be really tricky because, you know, we might well apply when we feel like we're ready, but we can't know who else is applying and, you know, what the calibre of other applicants might be. We have to hope that any recruitment processes are robust and valid. And of course, we just have to kind of trust in that process but you know sometimes people do get on to training courses on their first attempt and so I had a little look at some stats from the alternative handbook 2021 edition and people definitely do get on from first attempt. So from the respondents I looked at, I flicked through, you know, Bangor, East Anglia, East London, Edinburgh, Essex, Exeter and Hertfordshire.
因为这可能非常棘手。你知道，我们可能在觉得自己准备好时申请，但我们无法知道还有谁在申请，以及其他申请者的水平如何。我们必须希望招聘流程是稳健且有效的。当然，我们只能信任这个过程。但你知道，有些人确实在第一次尝试时就进入了培训课程。所以我看了一些《2021年替代手册》的数据，人们确实在第一次尝试时就成功了。我浏览了Bangor、East Anglia、East London、Edinburgh、Essex、Exeter和Hertfordshire的数据。
That's the ones I flicked through. So 36%, 22%, 29%, 41%, 45%, 13%, 22%. This, of course, is only that percentage of applicants. And I noticed that there were no respondents for Coventry and Warwick. And it might be that there's other courses as well that had no representation. But I don't ever remember getting a survey and I do wonder I would like your opinion if you know that this is not true or even if it is true I do wonder if they only sample BPS members because I was only a BPS member I think for part of my first year so
这些是我浏览过的。分别是36%、22%、29%、41%、45%、13%、22%。当然，这只是申请者中的百分比。我注意到Coventry和Warwick没有受访者。可能还有其他课程也没有代表性。我不记得收到过调查，我很好奇——如果你知道这不是真的，或者即使是真的，我也想知道他们是否只对BPS成员进行抽样，因为我在第一年的部分时间里才是一名BPS成员，所以
it might be that I wasn't a member when they sampled. But yeah, it seems strange that there was no respondents for a whole course. So yeah, we can only really take this as being the opinion of some people, perhaps the opinion of people who are more likely to fill in surveys as well. So it might not necessarily be, you know, an accurate depiction. But so it tells us that some people do get on first time but what it doesn't tell us necessarily is you know what their career journey had been like before they applied and of course what their age might have been like and you know what they wrote on their form there can be many many different things that the the data doesn't tell us. But of course, I also quite enjoyed the fact that East London and Exeter and Hertfordshire
可能在他们抽样时我不是会员。但确实很奇怪，整个课程都没有受访者。所以，我们只能将其视为部分人的观点，也许是那些更愿意填写调查问卷的人的观点。所以它不一定是一个准确的描述。但它告诉我们，有些人确实第一次就成功了，但它没有告诉我们他们的职业生涯在申请前是什么样的，他们的年龄，以及他们在表格上写了什么。数据中没有体现很多不同的东西。当然，我也很喜欢East London、Exeter和Hertfordshire
had respondents who got on sixth time lucky. So, you know, if you don't give up and you keep changing and you keep reflecting and you keep the faith and you keep changing and you keep reflecting and you keep the faith um and you keep applying in terms of the nishkama um karma and the tawakkal and i'm so sorry if that is um if you do speak arabic i've got that horrendously wrong please do let me know um and i will i'll do like a a tv reframe where i have to apologize and say the correct pronunciation so I did try and have a google but I couldn't find anyone that told me how to pronounce it properly
有受访者是第六次才成功的。所以，如果你不放弃，不断改变，不断反思，保持信念，并继续申请——就Nishkama Karma和Tawakkal而言（如果说错了，如果你会阿拉伯语，请务必告诉我，我会做一个电视式的更正，道歉并说出正确的发音）。我确实尝试谷歌搜索，但找不到任何人告诉我如何正确发音，
so um yeah if I've got that wrong um then do let me know but it's kind of like well I'm going to keep trying I'm going to keep bringing my best to the show um and you know when it's my time I will be successful and I honestly believe that when you get there when you get on to your professional when you get on to your professional doctoral course whichever discipline of psychology that might be that it won't matter how many times you've applied because I firmly believe you'll get on when you're ready and when the right time for you is because what I wouldn't want for you is for you to gain a place and feel massively out of your comfort zones and like everything feels overwhelming. Let's take a little short break here and I do think because of the time of year even though I haven't got my
所以如果我读错了，请告诉我。但我会继续努力，继续为节目带来最好的内容。当时间到了，我就会成功。我真心相信，当你进入专业博士课程时，无论是什么心理学学科，你申请了多少次都不重要了。因为我坚信，当你准备好且时机成熟时，你就会成功。因为我不希望你获得名额后感到极度不适，觉得一切都让人不知所措。让我们在这里休息一下。我认为，尽管我还没有挂上圣诞树，但也许是时候切换到《有抱负的心理学家》播客的圣诞版片头曲了。
Christmas tree up it might be time to switch to our slightly Christmassy jingle from the Aspiring Psychologist podcast so this was the original jingle and I said I love it but I do wonder if it sounds a little bit too like a Christmas edition so I would love your thoughts and your feedback on what you think to the Christmas version hope you enjoy it I would love your thoughts and your feedback on what you think to the Christmas version. Hope you for listening hoped you liked those lovely sleigh bells so um thank you for everyone who's been in contact recently pitching yourselves um for episodes of the podcast it's been really lovely to hear from so many of you but please keep those um contacts
这是最初的片头曲，我说过我很喜欢它，但我不知道它听起来是否太像圣诞特别版了。我很想听听你们对圣诞版本的想法和反馈。希望你们喜欢。希望你们喜欢那些可爱的雪橇铃声。感谢最近联系我并为播客节目自荐的每一个人，听到你们这么多人的声音真是太好了。但请继续保持联系，
coming if you think you've got a unique interesting or just useful tale to tell um about your journey to becoming a qualified psychologist um do get in contact with me um and let's get you uh let's have a let's have a chat to see whether it might make a good podcast episode um because i love hearing from you and i like it that people you know feel like this is also your show too because it is you know this is about you it's done with you and for you um so yeah we're aiming to get more and more aspiring psychologists in the show as well as themes and debates that you might find interesting and useful too um if you don't want to be in an episode which is absolutely understandable do please get in contact with ideas that you want to potentially feature and have me discuss
如果你认为你有一个独特、有趣或仅仅是有用的故事，关于你成为合格心理学家的旅程，请务必联系我。让我们聊聊，看看它是否能成为一期好的播客节目。因为我喜欢听你们的声音，也喜欢大家觉得这也是你们的节目，因为事实确实如此。这是关于你们的，与你们一起完成，并为你们而做。所以，我们的目标是让越来越多的有抱负的心理学家参与到节目中，以及讨论你们可能觉得有趣和有用的主题和辩论。如果你不想参与录制，这完全可以理解，但请务必联系我，提出你希望我讨论的想法，
and I can then find a guest or I can just do it freestyle. So yeah very short and sweet episode today but I didn't want to leave you guys without an episode because I know that I've wound myself into a little Monday fabric of many of your lives and that is a wonderful privilege so thank you so much if you would welcome some more advice and support and guidance please consider coming along to the aspiring psychologist membership where we're doing lovely things and creating really nice group of people as well people are saying really nice things about it and it's helping them to develop their confidence and to feel supported especially if they don't feel supported in the workplace or if they haven't in the past so yeah if that describes you or if you just think that you could use with brushing up a bit on your
然后我可以找一位嘉宾，或者我可以直接自由发挥。今天的节目很短，但我不想让你们没有节目听，因为我知道我已经融入了你们许多人的周一生活，这是一种美妙的特权。所以非常感谢。如果你想获得更多的建议、支持和指导，请考虑加入“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”，我们在那里做着很棒的事情，也建立了一个非常好的群体。人们对它的评价很好，它正在帮助他们建立自信并感到被支持，特别是在他们在工作场所没有得到支持，或者过去没有得到支持的情况下。所以，如果这描述了你，或者你只是觉得你需要提升一下你的
confidence and your skills in things like CBT reflective practice then come on board it'd be lovely to have you there otherwise do please come and join our free facebook group as well it is the aspiring psychologist community bracket free group um and that's with dr marianne trent i do believe um but yeah thank you so much for being part of my world and i will look forward to catching up with you very soon for our next episode of the aspiring psychologist podcast take care if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide
自信心和在CBT、反思性实践等方面的技能，那就加入我们吧，很高兴有你的加入。否则，请务必加入我们的免费Facebook群组，即“Aspiring Psychologist Community（免费群组）”，由Marianne Trent博士管理。非常感谢你们成为我世界的一部分，我期待着在《有抱负的心理学家》播客的下一集中很快与你们见面。保重。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南，
with this podcast that you'll start to be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that
通过这个播客，你将开始迈向合格的道路。这是Marianne Trent博士的《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我叫Jana，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。达到这一目标有这么多不同的途径，这让我感到惊讶，而且没有成为心理学家的完美方式，这让我充满了信心，
no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我不觉得我在做错什么，也减轻了自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。